uh this is exciting literally my  favorite show you've been hyping it up  for a while now all right season one  episode one let's do this oh boy it is  raining cats and dogs out there well  it's good to see you jack too bad about  your twins getting suspended uh the  first episode is being still trying to  find its footage let me watch I have  another date with Carmen tonight here we  go again this character gets so much  better later on he honestly sucks right  now it seems fine to me you're  eventually gonna realize how stupid you  sound but I like it so far no this is  terrible you should not be enjoying this  it's not that bad this is some of the  worst TV I have ever seen in my life  okay then just turn it off I don't want  to watch this okay  it gets really good after season nine